[Musique]
maîre bonjour bonjour présentez-vous
sucintement je suis olivieru 51 ans
avocat
puis alors généralement je triche mais
jusqu'à récente ich en augmentant
maintenant je diminue enfin ça fait 25
ans la réité c'est que ça fait 25 ans
donc j'ai dédié mon activité depuis
l'origine aux technologies d'ination et
j'essaie de faire de mon mieux pour que
ça dure quel type de dossier vous êtes
amené à App alors on traite de dossier
dans le domaine des technologies
d'information comme je l'ai dit on va
dire que ça tourne autour de trois
grands thèmes contrefaçon malfaçon
et ce qu'on appelait jusqu'à récemment
la fraude informatique maintenant c'est
la c'est on va dire la
cybercriminalité vous êtes l'avocat d'un
dossier qui sur Internet est nommé le
dossier Bluetooth h est-ce que vous
pouvez nous nous en parler un peu plus
en détail VO c'est un arrêt qui a été
rendu par la cour d'appel de Paris
récemment et qui a fait un peu grand
bruit puisque après que nous ayons
obtenu la relaxe du dénommé Bluetooth
devant correctional de créteille bien c
d'appel à affirmer la décision et à
condamneré le prévenu donc Bluetoth pour
maintien frudu dans un système de
traitement automatisé de données
et pour résumer très schématiquement
dossier he très grossièrement évidemment
en quelques mots en gros Bluetoth est
accusé pour après une requête naturelle
sur Google d'avoir eu accès à des
documents d'une agence de l'État l'an
pour pas la nommer dans le domaine de la
santé publique avoir eu accès à ces
documents et puis en avir pris naissance
et avoir fait quelques articles de
presse sur des contre-rendus ou des
présentations faites dans des groupes de
travail de l'ancess et le délit précis
qui a été reproché à Bluetooth et qui a
donné lieu la condamnation par la cour
d'appel de Paris c'est ce qu'on appelle
le délit de maintien frauduleux dans un
système de traitement automatisé de
données c'est un article du code pénal
l'article
3231 qui condamne au peine maximale pour
ce délit de 2 ans de prison et de 30000
€ d'amende
euh les personnes qui sont donc euh euh
coupable de ce de ce délit bon euh nous
nous sommes euh maintenant devant la
Cour de cassation nous avons formé un
pourvoir nons remettre notre mémoir dans
les prochains jours et euh nous espérons
obtenir que cet arrêt soit cassé
dites-moi est-ce que Google a été
poursuivi euh dans ce dossier-là est-ce
que Google a été saisi est-ce que Google
a été prévenu qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire alors Google poursuivi non
Google
effectivement avec ses robots avait
recensé un lien qui dirigeait vers ses
contenus qui étai mis à disposition du
public probablement même certainement
puisque ça a été reconnu par la suite
par erreur de la part de lancess mais
Google n'a pas été poursuivi ça c'est
certain prévenu probablement à part les
clameurs de la foule sur internet je
pense que Google n'a pas été interrogé
ne figure pas au dossier comme même pas
témoin ou auditionné comme témoin par la
police en l'occurrence c'était la direct
centrale du renseignement intérieur de
la DCRI qui avait mené l'enquête de
police contte tenu de la personne de la
du plignant
d'anè donc ni poursuivi ni interrogé en
tout cas officiellement en figurons pas
au dossier prévenu peut-être et est-ce
que le juge a soulevé le fait que
peut-être Google avait copié aussi les
fichiers sur ses serveurs basés aux
États-Unis alors ça c'est un point qui a
pas été dans laesure Google était pas
présent aux audiences puisque vous savez
dans les audiences correctionnelles le
tribunal ou la cour refont
instruction certaine manière de la faire
l'enquête en l'occurrence cette question
là n'a pas été traitée puisque Google
était pas présent nétait pas
convoqué dans la logique du parquet qui
a poursuivi Bluetooth ben effectivement
c'était des questions qui auraient pu se
poser qu'est-ce que votre client
risque il
risque les les peines prévues les peines
maximales prévu par le délit qui lui est
reproché sont de je l'ai dit de 2 ans de
2 ans d'emprisonnement pardon et de
30000 € d'amende c'est P
maximale bon c'est des peines théoriques
dans la mesure où dans l'affaire et
c'est un peu ce qui nous ach dans la
faire
bluetoof même si techniquement ça
n'empêchait pas de faire au parquet de
poursuivre de dossier vous n'avez pas de
victime vous avez un plignant à
l'origine l'an mais l'an c'est'est pas
constitué parti civile à aucune des deux
audiences au tribunal et la cour d'appel
enfin en tout casétait pas constitué au
tribunal donc forcément pas la cour
d'appel il n'y a pas trouur public à ma
connaissance par exemple les questions
de santé publique sont traitées par
cette agence on aurait pu imaginer que
les problématiques de santé publique se
posent dans ce dossier dans les dans les
documents qui ont été retrouvés par
Bluetooth ça n'est pas non plus le cas
et et donc au final on
a une une question de principe ou ou une
position une posture qui a été prise par
le parquet contre
Bluetooth qui sur le plan encore une
fois de l'état d'esprit dans le cas doit
être mené une procure pénale nous nous
choque voilà et effectivement ça a été
dit notamment par mon client il y a vu
un certain acharnement et cela pose des
questions par rapport à son propre
statut même s'il n'est pas journaliste
professionnel il a écrit il a écrit sur
des affaires sensibles comme par exemple
les affffaires exactement l'affaire
amésis et la vente on va dire d'outils
de surveillance électronique à la libi
de Kaddafi Eagle vous parlez de Eagle
oui et et et donc il a écrit sur des
sujets sensibles et évidemment on ne
peut pas s'empêcher de de de rapprocher
cette situation de de celle qu'il vit
dans le casadre du procédure vous savez
pour une personne un individu personne
physique un
particulier vivre une procédure
judiciaire en particulier pénal c'est
une épreuve et c'est une épreuve qui
dure dans le temps c'est une affaire qui
dure maintenant depuis plus d'une année
pour Bluetooth et donc évidemment c'est
quelque chose de difficile à Vire chose
qui va qui laisse des traces dans votre
vie on ressort pas d'une affaire pénale
comme on était avant et et donc cette
épreuve là est-ce que vous sentez que
c'est un boumissaire ou c'est plutôt une
carence de formation de notre notre juge
ou quand quand on entend que le juge
c'est le juge ou le procureur qui dit
Google Google bon alors ça oui c'est
c'est effectivement il y a eu lorsque au
tribunal correctionnel la problématique
ne s'est pas posée mais il se trouve qu'
effectivement il y a eu des
contre-rendus d'audience moi j'y étais
je peux confirmer leur véracité deux
journalistes présents qui ont été
effectivement choqués frappés étonnés
euh effectivement vous avez dit par le
l'utilisation du mot googler euh login
pour login enfin bon il y a eu un
certain nombre de de de mots prononcés
par celui qu'on appelle le conseiller
rapporteur qui rapporte l'affaire en
audience publique qui est celui qui qui
a étudié le dossier avant que la cour
euh finalement de siège qui montrait
effectivement on va dire une certaine
distance vis-à-vis mes connaissances une
de l'Internet bon peut-être mes
connaissances c'est pas à moi donc juger
maintenant j'ai déjà répondu à ces
questions quand on me l'a posé c'est
vrai je vous l'accorde mes connaissances
c'était assez manifeste mais ça
n'empêche pas euh on ne demande pas à un
magistrat qui traite de droit du
bâtiment d'être un maçon on lu demande
pas non plus d'être un geek lors qu'il
traite de technologie de l'information
c'est vrai que peut-être ministère de la
justice devrait faire un peu plus
d'effort vis-à-vis des magistrats parce
que peut-être la différence notamment
des services de police où on a très tôt
spécialisé
professionnalisé peut-être plus les les
les services de police que la
magistrature peut-être qu'il y a un
effort à faire mais ça n'empêche pas
quand même une cour et des magistrats de
statu c'est ce qu'ils ont fait est-ce
que votre client a reçu le soutien des
journalistes professionnel est-ce que
votre client a eu un appui est-ce que
alors il a reçu beaucoup de soutien
effectivement alors pas de la profession
organisée on va dire des journalistes
organisés pas de la corporation pas ma
connaissancein maintenant on a eu des
réactions après arrêt de la presse on va
dire organiser de la corporation je
pense en particulier à
miapart et à son directeur qui se sont
exprimés publiquement sur la
condamnation oui effectivement il y a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de soutien mais on
peut pas dire que pas pas de la
profession organisée pas de la comme
vous avez dit de la corporation j'ai une
question j'ai une question à vous poser
concernant la loi de programmation
militaire est-ce que vous pouvez me
donner votre avis écoutez pour moi ça
peut peut-être étonner mais cette
problématique de votre programmation
militaire loi du 18 décembre 2013 qui a
été suivi quelques semaines plus tard
par une loi sur la glocalisation
euh sans contrôle du juge
euh les différentes problématiques
Google 100% contrôle du juge mais avec
un contrôle du bureau du premier
ministre alors pour les lois de
programmation militaire effectivement
une personnalité désignée par le Premier
ministre en coordination avec une
autorité administrative indépendante qui
a terminé je me rappelle jamais de la
déation exacte de cette autorité mais
qui effectivement contrôle les
interceptions de sécurité je vais je
vais parler sous votre contrôle est-ce
que vous pensez que la loi de
programmation militaire c'est une
extension des écoutes administratives
ben d'abord enfin vous avait oui alors
c'est une exenstion d' écoute
administrative mais on a on a dépassé l'
stade de l'écoute là c'est ça le
problème c'est plus le service qui va se
brancher sur la ligne et qui va écouter
ce qui ce qui se passe ou qui va même
intercepter ce qui se passe l'air Pino s
simple fi qui est terminé voilà là on
est dans le recueil de données on est
dans la captation de données le recueil
de données dit loi c'est-à-dire qu'on va
chercher chez des prestataires chez des
intermédiaires techniques on va chercher
des données toutes données ça peut être
des courriel électronique des courriels
des courriers électroniques ça peut être
des données bancaires ça peut être des
mots de passes c'est tout ça dont il
s'agit donc et qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
ça alors quand on a un soupçon parce que
c'est ça la réalité c'est ça le
déclencheur lorsqu'on a un soupçon sur
une personne et ben on enquête et on
enquête à condition évidemment que il y
a un certain nombre de sujets qui sont
euh dans la voie de programmation
militaire qui sont le terrorisme
international la Sûreté nationale mais
également la défense du patrimoine
économique et culturel de la France mais
il y donc ça veut dire la contrefaçon en
bande organisée et notamment la fraude
fiscale là aussi en bande organisée donc
on a un ensemble de délit euh assez
variés au final et dès que ces délits
sont mis en en en action que des
soupçons se portent sur une personne de
manière administrative
je vais prendre une image forte et bien
les services de police ont maintenant la
possibilité légalement de mettre la main
dans le PO de confiture d'aller ouvrir
les boîtes à électroniques de prendre
lesadresses de prendre les mot de passes
de prendre les coordonnées bancaires et
tout ça avec un contrôle pour moi je ve
dire clairement assez chaotique quasi
inexistant qui ne donne aucune garantie
au citoyen on a fait en France avec 10
ans de retard exactement 12 ans de
retard on a fait la petite petite sœur
de du de du
patriotact américain qui a été voté 3
semaines aprend avant après les
attentats de 11 septembre 2001 en
octobre 2001 par l'administration Bush à
l'unanimité du Congrès donc sénateur
républicain et démocrate ensemble vous y
voyez un
danger conduite contre le terrorisme
international c'est légitime c'est
légitime c'estre intérêt à tous c'est
pas une menace virtuelle pour le coup
c'est une menace réelle et même si elle
est numérique là le danger que je vois
il est à deux niveaux c'est l' c'est
l'absence la quasi absence de garantie
des citoyens qui pose également question
aux États-Unis aujourd'hui et je
rappelle que en 2012 le Congrès
américain a voté la prorogation pour un
certain nombre d'années je crois pour 5
ans du patriotacte et qui a un sénateur
démocrate c'est la première fois qui a
déposé un amendement pour demander de
plus de garanties aux citoyens est-ce
que vous avez son nom j'ai pas son nom
comme ça mais je peux vous je peux vous
le donner et bien cet amendement a ét
refusé mais l'amendement a été demandé
donc premièrement absence de garanti
citoyen deuxièmement et c'est
particulièrement criant aux États-Unis
la NSA lorsqu'elle passe le programme
prisme on est dans la mouvant dans la
famille du patriotacte et de la voie
programmation militaire le message
qu'elle donne aux géants du Web et à
ceux qui ont signé ce programme desè
2007 c'est Microsoft qui a signé le
premier c'est Google c'est Facebook
c'est Apple enfin ce sont neuf
entreprises et le tout avec Verizon
Verizon euh
elle dit quoi ces géants du web elle dit
surveillez les populations je vous donne
le blancin on peut pas à la fois dire à
ces gens-l vous limitez votre
surveillance et en même temps je veux
que vous me donniez toutes données que
vous allez collecter sur des personnes
que je vais vous désigner pour vous pour
vous est-ce que c'est une démarche des
gouvernements pour identifier largement
sa population pour mapper sa population
parce que sa population est en train de
devenir un risque pour la stabilité de
l'état et pouvoir régalien de l'État
alors je vais vous répondre en deux
temps je dirais un l'enfer est pavé de
bons sentiments ok les bons sentiments
c'est la lutte contre la terrorisme
international j'ai aucun problème mais
le deuxième étage de la de la de la de
de l'immeuble c'est que en dessous la
NSA en dessous la dcriri en dessous tous
les services de de l'État qui luttent de
manière légitime contre l' contre la
fraude fiscale contre la contrefaçon et
ceter ou ils écoutent quand même les
journalistes ils saisissent les fadettes
existe des ordinateurs à l'étage en
dessous vous avez Google vous avez
Facebook qui eux surveillent les
populations mais de de manière de plus
en plus serré et qu' le font pas pour
les buts que je viens de vous dire eux
ils font du marketing prédictif eux ils
sont capables de vous dire que quand
vous levez le matin vous allez vous
gratter l'oreille droite avec votre
après avoir bu un verre d'eau
d'hôtelf je veux dire ils sont ils sont
ils vont très très loin aujourd'hui dans
les prédictions et c'est pour ça qu'ils
le font c'est pour le business c'est
pour gagner de l'argent et ces sociétés
là ont monté un business model qui
implicitement au moins a été accepté par
la NSA et par tous les services de
police et quand quand quand vous me
déployez ce constat j'ai j'ai une
question qui me vient à l'esprit est-ce
que ce n'est pas peut-être une
forfaiture de de notre système
judiciaire de nos juges pour protéger no
nos concitoyens ou c'est tout simplement
de la compétence pour parler
trivialement ils sont complè largué par
rapport à la loi de mour qui s'applique
aussi sur les systèmes d'information
bien sûr et par démission il laisse
faire soit conseillé par des lobbyes qui
connaissez l'ampleur des lobbies au
niveau de travail législatif donc pour
vous est-ce que c'est c'est peut-être
une démission ou c'est simplement non je
dirais pas une démission je dirais même
pas une
incompét non même pas je dirais un
manque de
vision un manque de compréhension un
manque de hauteur sur la problématique
oui parce qu'on est en train de mettre
en place une système de la surveillance
mais comme ça jamais existait dans No
société j'ai écrit un article sur mon
blog qui s'appelle l'arrière grand-père
et l'arrière Petitfils disent non à
programmation militaire et qu'est-ce que
je dis on est dans une système où votre
arrière- grand-père il descend de de de
chez lui il sort de sa maison il va chez
son libraire chez son boulanger et vous
avez les services de police qui disent
libraire et boulanger tu vas noter les
heures d'entrée et de sortie de de ce
monsieur et quand il va prononcer une
parole tu vas la noter et tu vas me
noter le prix qu'il te paye comment il
te paye combien il te paye et cetera
maintenant dans un système de
surveillance te paye s'il a transpiré
quand il te P complètement complètement
on est dans un système qui est celui-là
aujourd'hui le boulanger ça l'intéresse
de faire ça parce que il va pouvoir
comme vous dites mapper sa clientèle il
est dans son business
model et et voilà c'est son système ce
qui est totalement MOS normal c'est que
on l'encourage dans ce dans ce système
là par la mise en place de ces sociétés
donc vous êtes en train de me dire pour
résumer aussi trivialement le boulonger
devient un auxiliaire de police sans
sans la légitimité tout à fait j'appelle
ça un supplétif vous appelez à ça un
auxiliaire parce que moi je suis
auxiliaire de justiste en tant que
qu'avocat donc j'ai du respect pour le
mot auxiliaire pour le mot suppétif
moins donc je dis plutôt un suppétif
mais oui mais c'est ça le programme
prisme j'ai assisté récemment de au
dîner annuel d'un d'une organisation
dans le domaine du clat computing
comment ça s'appelle qui s'appelle
euroclad France qui est une très bonne
organisation je suis son secrétaire
général donc je vais pas cracher un
soupe mais il se trouve que c'est vrai
que c'est une organisation très
intéressante il se passe des choses et
on avait dans le cadre de C dîner on
avait invité notamment out la BPI la
banque d'investissement public voilà euh
un responsable d'un très grand fond
d'investissement dans dans la en
Californie et dans la Silic
quel nom j'ai j'ai plus le nom de cette
personne et cette personne nous a dit
quelque chose qui m'a frappé elle a dit
moi nous aujourd'hui avec l'affire
prisme on ne veut plus entendre parler
du gouvernement nous dans dans dans
Californie il nous a fait trop de mal
trop de mal ou trahi il nous a fait trop
de mal avec la NSA avec prisme et cetera
ou peut-être trahi trop de mal au niveau
de la confiance au niveau de la
confiance on parle de ça parce qu'il y a
pas de business sans confiance et vous
savez aux États-Unis c'est c'est
l'attaque du business finalement qui
fait réagir le mieux des choses et je me
suis dit euh cette remarque là me montre
que rien ne va changer que depuis prisme
et snowon rien ne va changer
c'est-à-dire
que c'est trop facile d'accuser le seul
gouvernement américain gouvernement
américain lui il lutte contre le
terrorisme et encore une fois ça me
paraît parfaitement légitime il défend
ses citoyens contre une menace qui est
réelle et et je nai pas de problème
là-dessus mais par ses actes et par ses
agissements et par son manque de vision
des
choses finalement il met en place une de
surveillance que que lui-même ne met pas
en place qui est mis en place par
d'autres et si ces autres si ces
entreprises là ces géants du web ne font
pas leur autritique et le peuvent-il
puisque ça veut dire modifier leur
business model modifier leur le leur
leur modèle économique hein je rappelle
que le modèle économique de Facebook et
de Google
contrairement aux apparences pour
prendre le dernier c'est pas de faire un
moteur de recherche ou d'éditer
gratuitement des des solutions de
bureautique hein on sait que très bien
c'est le marché de la publicité et et du
marketing qui les
intéresse bah ces sociétésl ont un
business qui exige qui qui qui passe par
la surveillance des populations et et je
trouve dommage que les services de
l'État ne limitent pas et au contraire
courage ce système je vais vous poser
deux dernières questions la première
sera votre perception en tant que
citoyen en tant peut-être père de
famille en tant que peut-être aussi
avocat qu'est-ce qui se passe on en est
où on va où question à long terme mais
je pense qu'on est aujourd'hui on est
sur un processus de tsunami c'est-à-dire
que l'affaire snodon qui ne date que et
moi je l'appelle la faire snoden mais en
fait je ne l'appelle pas habituellement
la faire snoden parce que pour moi c'est
l' prisme St wind oui alors en plus mais
c'est pour moi le problème n'est pas
Edward Snowden le problème c'est prisme
donc je crois que c'est un tsunami un
tsunami ça se passe il y a d'abord une
secousse hein et
ensuite on a les effets les
symptômes en à l'été
2013 les clients de toutes ces sociétés
qu'on signé avec la
NSA depuis ce depuis juin 2013 depuis le
6 juin 2013 arti du Washington Post
avant Guardian le lendemain ces clients
là ces abonnés là ces adhérents ces
membres là peuvent dire ces sociétés-là
m'ont trahi et ça veut dire que la
confiance est est est aujourd'hui de ces
entreprisees effectivement elle est
méchée elle est elle est entachée elle
est bréchée entachée et donc si cette
confiance s'en tâche et on on en a des
pour moi des signes avantcoureurs
pratiquement quotidien on voit le nombre
de membres Facebook en diminution les
achats de cette entreprise là à mon avis
témoignent quand même d'une prise de
panique une prise de conscience des
choses or ils ne peuvent pas évoluer ne
peuvent pas changer de business model
c'est le cœur de leur de le de leur
réalité et bien si cette confiance
continue effectivement à cette défiance
continue à augmenter plutôt et bien
c'est la société effectivement c'est
l'État qui risque d'en souffrir et les
réseaux numériqu et état c'est des c'est
une nouvelle industrie d'anonymisation
qui va se mettre en place qui va faire
que les soyens vont s'anonymiser ou
quitter les réseaux même si c'est un
mouvement encore ultra minoritaire
aujourd'hui on rencontre des gens qui
vous disent ne m'envoyez pas de courrier
électronique quand quand vous quittez
quand vous quittez les réseaux vous êtes
considéré comme suspect maintenant vous
oui effectivement c'est aujourd'hui très
encore c'est normal c'est un
comportement très minoritaire et à
contrecourant allez une dernière une
dernière question
si vous aviez la possibilité de laisser
un conseil au jeunes génération qui nous
écoute quel conseil vous leur laisserie
sur Internet comme une bouteille à la
mer moi je le je leur dira apprenez à
être le stratège de votre identité votre
identité c'est c'est votre liberté deain
et et donc apprenez à être le stratège
de votre
identité maîre merci beaucoup merci à
vous
l'idée de la commission trilatéral vient
de David Rockfeller il y a 35 ans il a
réuni quelques dizaines d'Européens
d'Américains de japonais en leur disant
écoutez on a des problèmes en commun euh
par
exemple les relations avec la Chine par
exemple les euh relations avec
ce qui était à l'époque
l'URSS essayons d'avoir des positions
communes qui soient dans l'intérêt
général je sais pas si si une heure avec
une promo d'un Master de Sciences Po est
un échantillon représentatif une chose
dont je suis sûr c'est que sur les les
10 jours qui viennent de s'écouler il y
a 5 personnes qui sont venus me voir en
disant ah tu sais quoi j'ai quitté
Facebook et pour beaucoup ils m'ont dit
c'est suite à une conversation qu'on
avait eu ensemble aujourd'hui ce que
j'aimerais ce qui serait vraiment génial
de la part de tout le monde c'est
commençons à créer des des produits
alternatifs qui permettent de conserver
la neutralité des réseaux et la
neutralité du net au cas où les autres
se fermeraient et où l'optimisme de
Jean-Manuel ne se vérifierait pas voilà